This is not because I don't enjoy lecturing.
I love lecturing and I get a great deal out of the experience.
And I see my role in lecturing to enthuse students,
but in terms of active learning,
just sitting there for 50 minutes for one thing, why 50 minutes?
Why, why do we stop people in here for an hour or 50 minutes to an hour?
Why that quantum of time.
All right, professor, where are you standing at the moment.
I'm standing in the largest lecture theater in the physics building and actually
one of the largest lecture theaters of the university of Nottingham.
What we're going to talk about today is the depth of the lecture we're in the
midst of a pandemic and higher education and lecturing is going to be
changed or is in the process of being changed dramatically.
There's a wonderful quote from Virginia Wolfe.
University lectures are an obsolete practice inherited from the middle ages.
When books were scarce to swallow instruction from a lectern is like sipping
through a straw lectures, ponder to the vanity of the lecturer.
Do you agree with that? I do. I agree entirely with that.
Uh, lectures dead. Should they be dead?
Definitely not.
I guess it's been given a particular currency because of locked down and the
fact that we haven't actually been able to give lectures and the fact that we
actually finished up our teaching for this academic year online,
but actually the discussions been going on a lot longer than that.
And what's really precipitated.
It was the prevalence of lecture capture.
The fact that lecture capture is happening,
that we're basically videoing and recording all our lectures and making them
available to students. And so then the obvious question you ask is, well,
what was the point in being at the lecture? You know,
why don't I just listen to the lecture capture? Um,
and certainly my view is that they are not in any way interchangeable.
I think it is ridiculous that process whereby we just stuffed students into a
lecture theater and talk about them.
We've been doing that for centuries and it's really easy.
It's really easy for a lecture just to stand up here and talk. Particularly,
all you're doing is effectively taking notes from a book,
firing them out and expecting the students to absorb that by osmosis.
How do you really deeply learn something?
Do you sit and just watch somebody talk at you and listen to it,
or do you actively engage with it? So for example, at the moment,
what I'm trying to do is use,
try to do something called triplets on drums, which is basically dat dat, dat,
dat, dat dat, just three drums in a roll.
Now I can watch as many videos as I like explaining this is
how you do triplets or what a triplet is.
I'm not going to get any further in terms of engaging with that material or any
musical instrument,
anything you can think of in terms of how do you learn to play an instrument?
You practice, you engage with the material and you do something active.
So you burn it into your neurons. That's not what's happening in a lecture.
If you go to a lecture, you know, if there's a nine o'clock nature,
you've made a particular effort to be there.
You've kind of committed to going there. You're sitting there for an hour.
There are no other distractions.
You're surrounded by a whole bunch of other students who are all focused on
what's going on in the lecture. So I actually, you know,
it really kind of is going to be a completely different experience from watching
a YouTube video while you're doing three other things at the same time,
making yourself a cheese toasty and chatting to your mates.
You talk about the fact that students that are lecture, pay attention more.
Do they pay attention though? Are they just turning up?
Because they have to be ticked off a list? I mean, they don't have to be there,
right. And you know, nothing bad happens to them. If they don't turn up,
we'll ask why they weren't there. But actually, you know,
we don't kick them out of the university or anything like that. It really is.
I mean, you know,
you just want a little bit of pressure to get people to go to the lecture.
Then they bother to attend and they get all the benefits that come from actually
being in the lab.
There's a wonderful lecturer in Harvard physicist called Eric Missoura.
It's got this wonderful quote,
which is the traditional lecture involves transferring the notes from the
notebook of the lecturer,
to the notebooks of the students without going through the brains of either.
And that may be overstating the case a little bit,
but it's not overstating the case a lot. And again,
I see my role really about enthusing. It's about getting the students to say,
well, this is interesting work. This is a really interesting subject.
I want to find out more about this.
I want to do the coursework because the subject is interesting.
I want to understand this more,
but the intellectual heavy lifting doesn't come from me or shouldn't come from
me. It comes from the students and that's not what's happening in this type of
environment.
Really important when you're learning that there's a reasonable amount of
structure imposed on what you're doing,
that you're learning things in the right order,
that you're learning them from the right resources in a consistent way that
everything sort of fits together with everything else.
And the nice thing about the structure of a lecture is that that's sort of built
into it, right? That actually the lecture has all that has that flow to it.
It's sort of done in a very sort of consistent way.
Whereas if you're just dipping into, you know, this resource and that resource,
it's very hard to get that kind of structured learning,
which is an important part of the learning process.
Making sure that students focus within this environment and that something to
get, you know, we've got a nine o'clock lecture I'll get off-road,
I won't get awkward, but at least a structure there that is important.
But to me it seems like a real cop-out to say that while all we're doing is
structuring the material, we can do so much more without 50 minutes,
rather than just have the traditional.
Sure. We have some levels of interaction. You know, we have,
we give the students these little clickers that allow them to answer questions
during the course of the lecture. So there is sort of,
even in a large lecture with 200 students in it, I am getting that feedback.
Did that thing I just explained go across, right?
Or have I failed to explain it miserably?
In which case they're not going to be able to answer the simple multiple choice
question I've just asked them.
So there is lots of places where there is interaction,
even in the conventional lecture.
The lecture in its current format.
I would say we really do anything to need to think about the death of that.
But of course, we're not going to throw the baby out with the bath water.
So what we will do,
and I think it's sort of obvious the grand term that's being used is chunking,
which seems really strange. Cause you've been chunking for years.
Brady you've been breaking material open to five and 10 minute videos.
That's what we should do. Short five, 10 minutes, 60 symbols,
like videos on a particular topic accompanied with, for example, a simulation,
a piece of Java script or whatever that,
that code some of that with parameters and that can be adjusted and
changed so that students can effectively do a numerical experiment and
say, well, if he's talking about this, about you adjust these sliders,
what happens?
And that interactivity is important again in terms of getting the concepts.
And then we use the lecture slots,
whatever lecture slots we have as available as problems, classes,
and as discussion groups. And I'll set up some, here are some problems.
And what we're going to do is we're going to discuss those problems.
Now you can say, well, what are the students? Don't do the problems. Well,
what we do is we have some credit associated.
We have some marks associated with the coursework to encourage them gently to do
the work and to engage with the work that's.
There's this thing called the flipped classroom,
which is the idea is that basically in the classroom,
instead of the lecturer standing up and teaching things, the students have,
pre-read a bunch of stuff.
And then basically you get them to solve problems in the class.
You get them to interact with you,
to interact with each other and get much more of a dialogue going.
It's a nice idea in principle, uh, it worked, it clearly works to a degree,
but actually there is interesting evidence that suggests it's not quite the
golden bullet that some people have been arguing that it is.
There was a test done last year, uh,
by some researchers at MIT where they did the controlled experiment.
If some people being taught in a flipped classroom way,
some people were being taught in the conventional way.
They found that the overall attainment was about the same in both groups,
but actually the flip classroom group,
the spread of attainment was much bigger in that the better students really
enjoyed it and got a lot out of it and did better.
But the weakest students really struggled with it. And for example,
students from minority groups found it very hard. And in retrospect,
I think there are kind of obvious reasons for that, right?
That actually you would expect that if you're a slightly disenfranchised group,
if you come up with a way of teaching that really requires you to interact
effectively with the other students, then you're going to find it harder to do.
If you're,
they're not your natural social peer group that you've been interacting with.
Anyway. So I think, you know,
part of the argument against the traditional lecture is that there are new or
better ways of doing it. I would just caution that those newer,
better ways sometimes have some, some shortcomings of their own.
This comes home to me, I've had tutorial groups.
What's absolutely clear that one of the students in that group is absolutely
uncomfortable with being in that small group and being sort of on the edge of
their seat.
Maybe I'm going to get asked a question and I don't know this and what are the
others going to think of me?
So what we have to do is just recognize that there are different ways of
learning other students. For example,
in a tutorial group are rushing to the board to do things, but some aren't.
So we have to have a blended approach to learning.
It's sort of obvious in some ways, but again, just stuffing,
lots of people in here and talking at them is not the way to do it.
I've heard you're a good lecture. Do you not?
Do you not think they've added something unique to people's university
experience into their education sitting in your lecture.
If I've enthused people? Yes,
but I want them to come away from this not going well. I listened to that.
That was amazing. I've learned a lot.
I want them to come away with a going I've listened to that.
That was really amazing and interesting.
And then he was very enthusiastic about it. I want to learn more.
That's the key thing and which is exciting.
It depends on the lecturer. It's interesting, right? Some of my colleagues,
you know,
sometimes they end up with what looked like deadly dull subjects to lecture,
but they find exciting ways to present them.
Others sometimes look like they've got the most exciting,
optional thing that will, you know,
tell people about cutting edge research in some area or other.
And they managed to sound it, make it sound deadly, dull. Um,
so it is a bit varied.
I just don't think you improve that situation dramatically by just changing the
medium you're using for teaching.
Phil. I know that you really love music are your best music experience.
The times when you've listened to songs at home on your own chunks of music and
things like that,
or has it been when you've been at concerts with thousands of other people,
seeing them in the flesh?
Brilliant, absolutely brilliant point. Brilliant. Yes.
That collective communal experience sort of, it is very, very important.
And that interaction between the students is very important.
I am not suggesting that we get rid of that.
I'm suggesting that what we do is we amplify that,
get them talking to each other during the lectures, get them arguing with me.
So finally,
a module I do called the politics perception of philosophy of physics,
which I think I've mentioned before the first time I did that because it's quite
different.
It's more like a humanity setup in that there are seminars and discussion
groups. So I'll talk for 20 minutes and then open up the floor.
I expected it to be tumbleweed.
These are physicists after all what traditional physics courses,
you just talk at them,
but the flood Gates opened and they debated and they discussed and they argued
in a friendly way. And sometimes yeah, no, usually in a friendly way.
And they argued with me as well. And that's what I want.
That's what should happen.
That's so much better than me statically sort of
given that, that information.
What do you say to someone who says, well,
Mike's the head of school at a university physics department. Of course,
he's going to advocate for something that, you know,
you can only get at a university.
Um, is that true statement? I guess that is a true statement. I mean,
it's true to an extent, uh, and there are people who are perfectly, you know,
autodidacts who can go out and really learn these things on their own.
I think probably the learning process intrinsically requires somebody to be
guiding you through it.
And wherever that guidance comes from a lecturer standing at the front of a
lecture theater or a tutor you're chatting with about your problems, trying to,
to understand a particular area of the subject, you know,
there will be different ways that guidance is given.
The lecture is just one of the ways that that guidance has given education.
Difficult lecturing.
Is easy. Some will disagree, but that's certainly my perspective on this.
I'm sure I hope this will generate some debate there.
I hope that common section or light up,
but I would argue that lecturing is easy. Education is difficult.
For example, we lecturers have,
are much easier job than secondary school teachers, high school teachers,
much easier job.
What about the heritage? Einstein gave lectures. This is a wonderful thing.
That's happened for so many years.
And now you want to have zoom calls and quizzes.
Einstein didn't have an iPhone.
So Einstein didn't, um,
communicate with people on the other side of the world, almost instantaneously,
Einstein lived in a different world and the physicist who Einstein
was teaching and the physicist that who were interacting with Einstein,
it was a very different time.
And the skills that you needed then are very different from the skills you need
today.
Having made the case for lectures and talking about how valuable you think they
are to education.
We're recording this during a pandemic where it looks like you're not going to
be able to give them for who knows how long, how catastrophic is.
The process has been nonstop in that we moved all of our teaching very rapidly
online in a very ad hoc fashion. When it all started,
we then got into assessment, how do we do exams?
We figured out ways of doing that. We've just completed the assessment.
We've just been returning the students, their marks.
The next thing on the list is, okay, so that's done now.
How do we teach it better next year? So we're already,
I was in a Skype meeting yesterday where we were discussing new methods for
teaching what technology we're going to use, what approaches we're going to use,
how are we going to split things up into smaller pieces?
How are we going to assure that there are, you know,
Q and a sessions with lecturers and ways for them to engage with the lecturer.
We're only working our way through that. Now, hopefully, you know,
this is not the longterm where we're going to be forever.
And so we're trying to develop things in a way that sort of blended that allows
us to combine face-to-face things with online things so that we can shift the
balance as times allow. Um,
but we're really just feeling our way through it at the moment.
Would anything be lost by the death of the lecture?
No. I don't think the depth of the traditional lecture format. No, I don't.
I don't think we will have the same elements. Um,
we will have the ability to have a lecturer who's there as hopefully
engaging is hopefully explaining the material,
but in a much more interactive way in terms of being led by the students,
rather than just going well,
I'll prepare my lecture notes the night before and just dumped them at the
students.
Who's going to win this. We're already seeing some universities saying, Oh,
we're going to go online next year. And things like that.
Are you going to end up being right here?
I think that in terms of how we modify the lectures, yes.
I would say it's not just, I've got to point out. It's not just me.
There were many other people who think along these lines, I think, yes,
we're going to see a change.
And I think the important thing is it's stuff that would have, you know,
two years ago would have said, if I want to do things this way,
the argument would have been well, just we don't have the resources to do that.
There's no way we can do that.
It's really interesting how this pandemic has focused on mind and things that
would have previously been absolutely beyond the pill suddenly are within reach
with this current pandemic. I think common idea of the side of it.
And during it, we got an opportunity really to radically change things.
And I would be so disappointed if we come out the other side of this and all
that happens is, well,
I've got a slightly higher resolution camera to fill my traditional lectures.
That will be so disappointing.
If you'd like to see both of the full length interviews that went into this
video,
I'm going to put the links on the screen and down in the video description.
I also think there's like a little bit of star power in a strange way to being
taught in person by a person who does the thing and knows the stuff.
Even if it's a lowly astronomer thing,
topic being taught astronomy by someone who's been there and done it and done
real astronomy and written papers and use the big telescopes has like a kind of
a, a star quality. If you excuse the pattern.
And also it means that, you know,
when they come up with questions at the end that weren't on the syllabus,
hopefully it means the lecturer can actually answer them because, you know,
they actually know the subject they had.
They don't just know the thing that they're teaching.
They don't just know the syllabus they're teaching.
They actually know the subject around them.
You can see plenty more videos too, with Mike and Phil,
both on 60 symbols and deep SKO videos.
I'm going to include links to those as well.